[Music]
my daughter carries my ex-wife's maiden
name and i took her to the doctor and
they said her her maiden name in front
of her she didn't understand she'd never
heard that name before a person's name
is a
deeply important part of a person's
psyche
[Music]
got a clock in my head dude listen
well number one this is the dr john
dolone show number two
the glow on turnstile wrecker dude is so
good i keep i got it stuck in my head
ah got a clock in my head
dude
the song mystery may be the best song of
2021 and 2022 and i don't even know when
that record came out i'm so late to that
game
turn style mystery as soon as this uh
episode is over go check that song out
so good and tlc
so good and my friend cody
came up with third eye blind tickets
we're gonna relive the 90s
and
probably some songs i can't sing anymore
but we're gonna relive the 90s i'm
pretty excited all right let's go
straight to the calls after my little
diversion there let's go to paul in
birmingham what's up paul
hey hey john what's up dude
how are you i'm good man yourself
i'm doing okay fantastic just uh
glad for the opportunity to pick your
brain about some things i'm i'm grateful
man what's up
uh well
about uh
about six years ago i got i got divorced
from my wife
uh she was having an affair
it was a
long-term affair
it was too much for me to get over at
the time so we we got divorced
and uh
during the time that we were
separated
she had
carried on with with this other guy and
she had become pregnant
and
that
that all didn't work out
and
during the time that she was pregnant
i started spending a lot more time over
there with my son
kind of helping out with with the family
we had been together for
about 14 years before this before the
separation and you all had kids together
yes sir we had one okay
and uh
well just
we kind of after being divorced for
about two years we kind of rekindled
things okay
and
she had a baby
girl that
i've been raising since
she was born okay
and i just
are you still with are you still with
your
did you get remarried is she still your
ex-wife what's the status she's still
she's still my ex-wife we we got back
together and right now we have no plans
to get remarried okay
uh but she does live with me okay and
we're raising
both the kids in the house and she
carries
my daughter carries
my ex-wife's maiden name
okay
and i took her to the doctor
uh
about a month ago
and they kept calling her her last name
out and and i never responded to it i
never really even thought about it
but
then when they they approached me
and they said her her maiden name in
front of her
she didn't understand she had never
heard that name before and she's you
know she's four and a half years old now
and it kind of
got me to thinking
about how fast she's growing and
we just
don't really know
the best way to deal with that okay
so it number one thank you for calling
number two thank you for seeing a child
in need and choosing to step into that
gap and to love this little girl and
raise her like your own it's noble okay
yes
um i'm also gonna be real direct with
you is that cool
that's cool so this is you and me just
having a drink hanging out and
um not me coming after you is that cool
yes okay
i believe
and i think the uh data would bear it
out but i believe that a person's name
is a
deeply important
um part of a person's psyche okay
um it's what anchors them
it anchors them in the present it's who
peop who people refer to them as it's
how they are known and to get really
it's going to sound woo-woo and we could
talk about the neuroscience
this idea of being known is incredibly
powerful do you know me and do you see
me and do you still love me those are
the cores to everything
everything
and
your name is how you're known it's how i
get your attention it's how we make
connection
and
it's not only the present but it's in
the past it's lineage it's this
ultimate answer to the most terrifying
question we can ask which is who am i
where am i from
and
one of the
um
one of the things that racism scholars
have taught me over the years is there's
something about having your roots torn
from the stalk
and not knowing lineage
i don't know where i'm from i don't know
who might p i can't trace my lineage
back because it stops right there does
that make sense so it's a trauma not
knowing where you're from not knowing
who you are and what you're connected to
and what you're tethered to in the
modern world we've made it about
um
genetic i want to know about genetics am
i predisposed to cancers or diseases or
do my dad have bipolar those kind of
things
this is i think a much much deeper root
of thing so i tell you all that to tell
you this
your daughter's got to know her name
she's gotta know where she's from
and then oh go ahead go ahead
we we have
we've been
um
because
her biological father
has has never wanted anything to do with
her okay he
he he knows that
she
biologically is his he knows it but he
he denies her he disputes it
have you adopted her do you have a legal
claim to her
i do not uh well through this through
the state
uh because we looked at it um
and let me just ask you this why aren't
you getting married like what because
here's what here's the deal
the arc i was making
all that who's my name and what's my
lineage and where am i from is all about
anchor
it's a tethering
and so i give you all this stuff about
names and anchors and all that
the single most tethering anchoring
thing for a child
is a stable mom and dad
a home
okay
a stable place to be anchored into
and y'all are playing house
well we're we're actually we're working
on the process of
the adoption uh-huh
uh because
he has to
it's complicated because there's no
signature on the birth certificate to my
knowledge we've been dealing with a
lawyer for about three years now this
should not this should not be a
three-year process it should be a very
very quick process either somebody you
should your wife should have the birth
certificate or your ex-wife does she
have it
she does okay is there a signature on it
not by it uh
not by a male
just just her name is on it
yes okay that happens all the time
there's single moms all the time with
dads who suck and they don't show up
common thing so she goes to the
courthouse and you go through the
process what i don't know is depending
on what state you live in i don't know
if any old random guy which is what you
would be considered
can adopt a kid
that's right and so the right now the
judge we've we've the lawyer has
submitted uh paperwork to our
our county judge
and
she didn't respond to it so she sent it
again and and it seems like every time
she sends it it takes months before we
hear anything back and
and it my point is i don't want to keep
anything from her
i just don't know
how but do you understand do you
understand the chaos so that she's
experiencing
and if you try to explain this like the
challenge you and i two grown educated
adults are having trying to track this
the four-year-old is going to read this
as chaos
oh no sir we don't we don't want
we don't want it anytime soon
i i i well
let me back it up this kid
okay this kid
and here
this is me just being straight with you
you're trying to have all sides of
you're trying to be in relationship with
this woman but not go through the hurt
again not go all in
you're going partly in
yes and so you're trying to hedge your
bet against a woman that let's be honest
you love her and she's
she's who you're spending time with she
lives with you
and you're trying to raise this kid as
though she's your own
but you haven't taken the legal steps to
make her your own so you're just playing
dad
and that's an important role right now
but you're not all in
and that girl knows you're not all in
that's it so
however i can say this it's not a
cognitive thing with a four-year-old
they feel it
okay
you are the most stable male presence in
her life make no mistake and what you're
doing is a noble thing what i'm telling
you to do is that this nobility wears
off because you're you're going halfway
okay and i would rather see you sit down
and go all in with mom again and create
a
bound home
this is who we are and where we are and
this girl will always be a part of our
lives
which means
you're gonna have to
do a lot of soul searching and forgiving
and your ex is gonna have to have some
life change which i'm assuming is all
that's happened otherwise she wouldn't
be living with you again
and we're going to create that stability
there i do i i don't know what you're
trying to gain by not
connecting this thing because if you're
married this is a very simple simple
process
yes
the complexity here i i don't understand
the hoop chiller jumping through that
may be three or four other phone calls
right
uh yes um
but you're trying to have it all without
going all in
and all the anytime you don't go all in
and relationally it creates chaos and
then you end up with all sorts of
downstream challenges
and that's on top of
this little girl needs to know like her
her name and her origin and her
birthright and she's going to have to
grieve and deal with the fact that her
biological dad wanted nothing to do with
her which will be a soul wound as they
call it forever
and she's gonna have to learn
that paul showed up
and said i chose you
and that's a different kind of love that
she's gonna have to learn to understand
what that even means right all that to
say is that's just playing playing
that's gonna play out over the next few
years i want her to have as hardcore of
an anchor into bedrock right yes
that's that's all i'm saying so i i
now i'm realizing as i'm talking to you
like i don't even know
if that that wasn't your question
um should i get married or not or should
i like what should i do so tell me what
your question is man how can i help
well i just
uh
my main thing was
in a perfect world
and you you kind of answered my question
is
my question was this this situation was
more about my daughter because i mean i
love her she
every morning she comes in she has to
get her cuddles for daddy before she
goes to school she has to lay in bed
with me for at least 15 to 20 minutes in
the morning before she gets up and gets
ready
but
you know my thing was
uh you know i i am considering
uh remarriage i just i was i was with
this woman for seven years
before i proposed to her yeah
and
you know when the affair happened
you know it kind of
and and then i i normalized being single
for two years and and
you know kind of set my path and then
and then we rekindled things and got
back together i was never expecting that
and then you know so things are are so
much different and
uh but now they're they're kind of
normalizing again it's been can we say
this out loud something can we say this
out loud
you got hurt real bad
oh yes sir i know that's not cool for uh
for a
southern alabama guy to say out loud
that woman ripped your heart out right
yeah yeah yes sir she did okay and after
seven years you slow played seven years
cause you didn't want to get hurt
and for whatever reason you've got
built-in alarm systems that say dude
relationships will get you hurt it'll
get you hurt it'll get you hurt and you
finally did it and it got you hurt
yes sir right
and so here you go here you find
yourself again
so i want you to remember this line i
say it a lot on the show but i'll say it
again
all relationship a hundred percent of it
is a risk all of it
yes sir and the unfortunate thing about
it is the only way
to get the beauty out of a relationship
is to go all in
and like going all in you can get hurt
don't do don't get remarried for this
little girl
get remarried because you and your and
your ex want to
build something totally new
yes
sir the main reason why we haven't
remarried yet why is that
because i didn't want
you know i thought about
the adoption
that that part was mainly if something
were to go wrong again between me and
her that she couldn't keep me from
from my daughter hold on
man i hate to say it like this but she's
not your daughter
yes sir i hate to be that guy dude
but she's not
okay you haven't go i mean legally she's
not your daughter your wife right now
could make one phone call and you could
never see her again
i understand right
now
in that little girl's mind in your mind
in your family's mind you are the only
dad she's ever known
and that's what i want to bring the gap
together from the reality that everybody
experiences in that home and the legal
reality and the truth reality and the
bedrock reality
and your picture you know like it's an
old cartoon where the the ice splits
and your legs start getting further and
further apart as those ice chunks start
floating away that's where you are right
now
yes sir bring it back together
and it might mean that y'all got to go
get marriage counseling which i know is
not a cool thing to do you got to go do
something and learn
we're going to build an awesome life
together
yes sir you know what i mean
that's
hard to hear but you but you're right
what do you love this woman
oh yes yes if you propose today would
you say yes
yes sir okay
so it took you seven years
what's the hang up this time
[Laughter]
i don't know this is certainly
eye-opening so
give me plenty to think about what's the
hang up you've got to hang up
what's the hang-up
you mean as to not getting married yeah
oh i mean she lives with you you're
trying to you're trying to connect be
connected to her for life through
parenting
you see that's like no i would suppose
i'd suppose it was the process of the
divorce was
um
it killed you huh
well yeah financially and and and then
just
the amount of stress yeah i actually had
a i had a
i had a complete and total loss of
appetite for two weeks i didn't eat
anything and i was never hungry and i'd
never experienced that before it was
stress and it's called trauma
it's called stress right
took everything from you your money your
soul your trust your heart
and
you're right back in it
yeah i guess it's just easier to
have to as you would say play playhouse
but let me tell you something crazy now
okay this is bananas um and it was a
shape shifter moment for me
our
brains can play house
we can uh i can work at a job that i
know is like
i've got a friend who works at a job
it's a terrible job it's killing him
literally killing him but the benefits
are good
and so he says something like oh man the
benefits are good and i might have to
pay for braces for all my kids and
whatever um and that's how he wraps his
head around it i've got another friend
who drives like a lunatic
but he has some sort of rationalization
the the the title of the book by vander
kulk is this the body keeps the score
so whatever story you're telling
yourself
your body knows
okay here's what i mean by that if you
haven't made peace with the fact that
you are back into a
full-fledged living in relationship with
somebody who hurt you
it's a recipe for dying young
it's a recipe for anxiety for stress for
heightened always on edge
forgiveness on the other hand is you
taking that brick that she gave you she
handed you a cinder block and said i
take everything from you
it's you setting that cinder block down
because it's not hurting her anymore
it's hurting you and you're carrying it
around set it down
and look at her and say i'm gonna do
this again
because i think she's changed and you
think you you think you've changed and
y'all are not gonna try to reclaim what
was you're gonna build something totally
new it's gonna be amazing for you for
her for your family for this little girl
for your son for everybody
yes sir does that make sense
it does i kind of a part of me knew you
were gonna say that and here's i've been
watching your show for a while here's
it could all happen again
yes sir i know that she could cheat on
you and hurt you again
and the risk is
i don't think i i think she's all in
and maybe that's the question is she all
in like are you all in
and has she given you that she
demonstrated the last couple of years
i'm all in i am all in on you
and maybe i was young and dumb and
immature and maybe i made some dumb
mistakes maybe
after seven years of dating your first
five or six or ten years of marriage you
weren't still wearing it all in you gave
her you you know
you liked her so you put a ring on it
and
you put a ring on it and then um but you
still weren't all in
and she felt that gap and she went
somewhere else to try to fill that gap
however it is what i wanna tell you is
this it sounds
counter-intuitive
um
but the only way to make a relationship
work especially marriage to go all in
pick your feet up and just go
and the only way to get hurt uh you can
get hurt anyway you can go all in and
get hurt you can drag your feet and get
hurt the only way to make it work is to
go all in
and if she's not the one i don't want to
push you to marriage dude paul if she's
not the one
then it's time to move on
it's time to stop playing house and say
i'm worth more than this i am going to
go have a relationship where it's equal
if you're back then forgive her
and say we're not going to play house
anymore we're going to do this thing
right and we're gonna be all in
and we're gonna give this little girl
stability that um she might otherwise
wouldn't have had and i'll tell you
again paul you're a man of character
you stepped into a gap where most men
would run her own dad ran
coward
but you didn't
let's do some soul searching and figure
out what's next
send me a wedding invitation
if it happens we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back
listen if you're about to buy a home and
make a big change save yourself the
headache and call churchill mortgage
today at triple eight loan 200. trust me
that's triple eight loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right what's up we are back let's go
to hannah in south texas hey this is a
follow-up call what's up hannah
hi how are you dr john i'm good how are
you
i'm just enjoying the warm weather
it is
that is a very uh optimistic way of
saying what's going on in south texas
right now
it's a little warmish yeah
a little warmish
um yeah we're just gonna we're gonna
take a little beach vacation on the sun
right yeah
this morning it was 74 in nashville and
i took a picture and sent sent it to my
friends and there's like uh rain in the
forecast most of the week and i sent it
to my friends in uh
in texas i was like hey what is this
what are these clouds with uh water
falling from them what does that mean
uh anyway so it's a billion degrees
right now in south texas right
it is yeah we're on the surface of the
sun for sure oh geez i'm sorry but not
sorry so what's up hey so there's a
follow-up call right
it is yeah okay so i'm gonna walk
through the original call
the original call is um you and
your
you were married
i was yeah and then your ex-husband
uh and then you got remarried right
y'all got divorced and you got remarried
and then your ex-husband ended up um
walking into an apartment or a home and
taking the life of a couple of people
and then taking his and then taking his
own life down by suicide is that right
yeah so it was his uh long-term
girlfriend and her son who was a close
friend of the sun that i shared with my
ex-husband all right what a mess miss
mess and we talked just a few days in
the aftermath of that so
um
walk me through it
um
so it's been a ride we're still on the
ride
you
had i've been a long time listener of
the show and was kind of following some
of the advice that you get and others so
when i presented
my son with the news
i kind of glossed over it and just said
that his dad had passed away
um and my call to you was how do i
have this conversation of the truth
because it is it was on the news and
um
it was very uh publicized and how do i
have this and reconcile what happened
with
this man that you know our son
worshipped as a hero so
um your son's got some um cognitive
exceptionalities right he's yeah he's
autistic
autistic with adhd um
and
he you know i i wanted to wait until the
investigation was closed before
presenting any fax and you would advise
that hey look if this is in the news
this is
it is what it is
um and that i wouldn't be taking
anything away but i had no role in this
and the best thing to do was to be
honest and open with with our son
and that's kind of where this journey
started
about a month after
the incident
we
took your advice and sought out
a counselor who specialized with
neurodivergent children and trauma so we
found that unicorn
that could accommodate a schedule and we
and then we started we started the
therapy journey we turned on the therapy
water hose where it was
um
you know
our son was going to therapy then we
were going to family therapy and i was
going to individual therapy because this
resurfaced a lot of trauma from my
marriage
my first marriage and then um
in doing that i had thrown myself into
taking care of my son and dealing with
all of my
trauma and the feelings and the
inconsistent feelings that i was having
because i couldn't understand why i was
sad
to and why i was missing someone that
had you know
it it was a an abusive marriage like how
could i i couldn't reconcile those
feelings so i was focused
elsewhere so then my current marriage
suffered and
my current husband is a police officer
not a great time to be a police officer
um gnarly ride for a few years yeah and
so he
was experiencing some things at work
and
he didn't have a partner
to check in with at home so he was
looking elsewhere and he unfortunately
like many
law enforcement officers do turn to to
drinking heavily and
that presented problems and resurfaced
trauma from being married to an addict
so
he he sought help and therapy on his own
so he now he's seeing therapy and then
we have couples therapy and family
therapy and
where if we're finally getting a
foothold and kind of coming together and
a lot of that
i lay at your feet because i will turn
on the podcast and it it never fails but
i turn it on and there's somebody in
some form or fashion on the show that is
going through
something that we're currently dealing
with well y'all are going through
everything so you're basically you're
basically in the show we're just going
to get it out we're going to rip the
band-aid off
you know we're going to rip the bandit
off just do it all at once yeah
hey you mentioned something really
important um is it okay if i ask you a
couple questions
sure um first how did the conversation
go with your
son and i ask that is um
i'm always interested if somebody calls
back and says hey we took your advice it
was terrible we should not have done
what you said
um
and also
most people could never imagine
having to sit down with their child and
say
your dad
did something horrific and your dad was
sick and your dad is no longer with like
the that is so out of the realm of
somebody's
somebody's
a normal just a regular run-of-the-mill
person walking down the street
walk us through that
um
so
the conversation i really didn't have a
choice but to have the conversation
because he found an article okay um and
the article kind of glossed over it and
just said that there there were guns
found at the scene
um
and so
this was after my call with you and
again got down i sat on the floor he sat
on the couch
and i i had to put it in context so we
watched a lot of the the law and order
type shows and i said you know how
when we're watching the show they can't
just jump to a conclusion they have to
put the pieces together
so
at the time i had given you the
information that i had which was
you know your dad
and the others
they had died
i didn't have details and the detectors
didn't have details but the detectives
had to do their job and put the pieces
together
and what those pieces determined was
that this happened
now just because this happened
um oh and i checked in with them i said
do you have any questions about that and
he said no
and all right so two things for the
person listening
real important when you have hard
conversations with kids even into their
early teens
getting below their level or getting eye
contact level with them is really
important when you have a hard
conversation from a power position one
down it can be unnerving for a child
puts them in a state of fight or flight
and then you have this hard news so
brilliant number one number two
genius
connecting a hard conversation to
something that your son can anchor into
yeah it's it's uh
my my i took my four-year-old when our
dog died and we buried that dog on my
friend's ranch but we dug the hole
together that moment has allowed us to
talk about death when grandparents and
when i could we have an anchor point and
you brilliant job great job you did
there awesome thank you so good
um
thank you
so he he said he didn't have any
questions
and i said okay what i need you to
understand and what i need you to
remember and i will be here to remind
you for all of your days
is that this in no way shape or form
has anything to do with you has anything
to do with how your dad loved you with
how proud he was of you it is not a
reflection on you
i was like your dad was sick
and i just left it at that
you are unbelievable
you're an amazing mom
thank you
like
for real that's really really powerful
yeah um
it's very hard um yeah
and we didn't
um you know we didn't start
therapy right away i said you know i'm
i'm looking for someone for you to talk
to
is that okay
and he said oh i think i'm good mom and
then i was like
okay
we'll watch this
um and i was interviewing several
therapists and if i didn't like the vibe
i i wasn't even going to to waste our
time
and then something
he was in spanish class and they had a
day of the dead project and they had to
make the little ofrenda where they had
to make the memorial and um
he really the only person that he knows
that's died was his dad so he made that
and that resurfaced a bunch of questions
um and so where i'm answering the
questions and i've always said even when
his dad was alive i'll answer any
question you want
um you know and
we were digging through photos and he
found a photo of
his his dad's biological father and he
said who's that and i was like that's
that's your grandfather that's your
dad's dad
well that doesn't look like papa and i
was like okay
okay this is your dad's dad
unfortunately he died when your dad was
younger
well how did he die
well
um
he committed suicide oh wow
so then you have this beautiful
autistic brain sitting as who looks for
patterns in the world that's right he
said well if my dad did it
and his dad did it does that mean i'm
going to do it
and never
never ever ever ever ever
did i think that i would
have to to answer or visit that question
yeah
um
and i the only thing i could say is i
certainly hope not because and the
difference is is you have a support
system and you have a mom who is here
for you and loves you and i will move
heaven and earth to get you whatever
help that you need do you want to talk
to somebody
mom i want to talk to somebody
got it and you know i had a list of
people that i thought were would be a
good fit and that's when we
started the weekly sessions with our
unicorn who's been great for the almost
year now so
it's been arrived it's been
yeah
can i change one thing for you to tell
this young boy moving forward sure if he
ever asks that question again
smile and say no
not i hope not not i think not
smile and say no
because now he has a um
he's got a path laid out in front of him
that he knows the ending of
and now that we know that if you drive
down that road here's what's at the end
of that road we're not going to take
that road and if we find ourselves on
that road we can hit the brakes
right
and
so we now have a path elsewhere
and this other path is going to be hard
because we don't know it it's going to
be new it's going to be us in the woods
that's what counseling is it's teaching
us how to make new paths in the woods
and someone's going to walk with us
that's what a counselor does um that's
what your unicorn does with you
um but the answer's just a smile on it
no
you're stuck with me for the long haul
yeah and when the light feels really low
we're gonna remember granddad and we're
gonna remember dad and we're gonna make
that phone call
and so in a strange way
a very strange way it's a surreal
experience you're having and i know that
um we're norming
death by suicide because it's happened
twice in the lineage
it is our life
right yeah
um it's our life and so since it's our
life same with um granddad was um
struggling with i don't know
uh
any number of things granddad had cancer
dad had cancer i now know i'm going to
be extra careful about my tests and
about my diet and about fill in the
blank right
um
granddad was uh 300 pounds overweight
and struggled with disorder eating his
whole life dad was struggling with
disordering i know i'm gonna have to be
on top of that stuff and so it gives us
a path right it's not deterministic but
it gives us a path so anyway that
i'm just telling you um you i mean you
listen to the show
i think uh you need to start your own
podcast on how to be a good mom i mean
it's just amazing it's amazing okay i
want to touch on one other thing before
i let you go is that cool sure um
because this comes up a lot a lot a lot
a lot
um
and that is
loving somebody
being in relationship with someone being
married to somebody being a partnership
with somebody
while they're experiencing trauma
and
the
this is a terrible analogy and so
forgive me and for everybody on the
internets who are mean just don't be
mean about this that's just a not a good
analogy but
um it's a time when i was a kid i was
riding a little scooter and i
slipped out in the street and my feet
got caught behind me and they were
dragging until i stopped
and so i pulled all the skin and down to
the muscle off of my feet and i ran
inside and my parents were gone and just
my sister was there and she was a kid
too so i'm not mad at all
but her first words were ah you're
getting blood on the carpet
not oh my gosh you look really hurt
and so there's something about being
connected to somebody who's struggling
and you've got a wound and you're
getting blood on the sheets you're
getting blood on the carpet
and yet i'm still trying to care i'm
trying to care about you because you're
clearly hurt
and there's a tension there when i know
my wife is
getting the care she needs she's getting
the counseling she needs she's been
through hell and back and why does she
keep talking about this x
why is she feeling so down what about me
why doesn't she right answer that
question what about me comes up and it's
not a people like to make it a character
thing it's not it's a human nature thing
do you still love me do you still see me
do i still belong and at the same time
you're going through hell
right
walk us through that in your marriage
oh um
so like i mentioned he was an officer
and he had experienced um
outside of just day-to-day trauma that
officers experienced true trauma
where um
you know a gentleman passed away in
custody
um
and
you know it
it led to
he's he's a very stoic
um
i don't want to put my burdens on you
and it's been like that since
the dating ages so
um very so i don't want to burden you
with my my problems i'm here to support
you and relieve you of everything you
carried in your first marriage is how
this has been and i i just kind of left
it at that and so i i wasn't checking in
because i got tired of checking in and
being like it's fine
i i don't you don't need to worry about
it like i've got it that that stoicism
um
left me not having a place to help him
um and let me say let me say that a
different way that stoicism is a brick
wall it's a concrete pillar
it's hollow
and it's less about you being able to
help him but there's no way for you to
plug in
right
that's exactly what it was so i and
that's that's what it had come down to
is i had checked out
that is i was like okay well if you
don't need me i need to help myself and
i know my son needs me so this is where
i'm putting my resources like um
and he
you know i threw myself into
fair you know individual therapy and
therapy for uh my son and and work got
crazy so i was trying to deal with
craziness at work and
you know let's throw in building a house
in this crazy market why not why not uh
and it's a billion degrees
a billion degrees surface of the sun so
the only thing that he had to do
not the only thing the the path that he
chose to take was drinking so a few
beers after shift turned into
a six-pack turned into a night cap
turned into
half a bottle turned into a bottle
and
so it it kind of we
hit um we hit the wall
um
around the holidays because there's
never stress at the holidays
um
and uh we hit the wall and quite
literally holes in the wall and i left
um and i said i'm not doing this again i
did it in my first marriage we don't
need this you figure yourself out any
good
so
can i say this
um
i have a friend who
his dog got hit by car
his beloved dog and he ran out in the
street to grab this dog and it reached
up and it bit him
it was hurt so bad
it just snapped right
and he ended up having to go to the
hospital and get stitches in his hand
and he was also heartbroken the dog
ended up passing away it was a mess
but i remember
him saying i can't be mad at the dogs i
was hurt
right and the dog mistook me for a
threat and
i tell you to say this
sometimes when we are recovering from
major trauma and from hurt and from pain
things just end up like you said all
over the place up against the wall like
all over the place and there's this
moment of the lights are on
i'm sorry and i still love you and i'm
sorry i still love you let's figure this
out and it sounds like that's been
y'all's adventure moving forward
yes
so
um
i i had offered
help up into up until that point and
again it's i couldn't plug in like we we
could we were so disconnected
um to it um
that i was like if you're not going to
talk to me you need to figure this out
um
and
and he did it was i mean the next day
phone calls were made
um
so he sought intensive treatment and
therapy
and and you know
we've been back together and it's been
we are making it work whether it be you
know telehealth appointments through
better help where you know he finds a
parking lot and i'm in the parking lot
at lunch and
we're we're having these couple weekly
couple sessions we're making that a
priority and still
working on ourselves and still working
to fix this for our son
and navigate what this looks like
because now we have to be the bridge to
the other side you know whereas before
it was his dad that was maintaining
those relationships you know the only
way to access this is for
us to to reach out to
his dad's family and say hey
what do what do you want to do i'd like
for you all to continue to be part of
his life
so we have this weird very modern
family-ish
thing
going on that neither of us ever thought
we would have coming from divorced homes
ourselves
where
once a month we're up with my
ex-sister-in-laws you know um in north
texas spending time so he can connect
with his cousins and all that other
stuff i
it's it's a wild wild ride and i just
thank you for starting us on it i think
i i just
i mean you can say thank you to me i'm
just in here in awe i'm i think i'm i'm
i'm thanking you
um for your bravery and for your
continued
getting back up and going again
and
the
the words that keep coming to mind as
i'm listening to you is you did it
anyway
you didn't want to have that hard
conversation he did anyway
and you didn't want to deal with the
trauma that you just tried to marry into
and to do away with you married a
a different version right
and of the same issue and
uh
then you decided to deal with the trauma
and you did it anyway and then your
marriage got really hard it got scary
and you decided to do it anyway and now
you're having to figure out a new life
that was not in your plans at all
and i i've come to believe that the
phrase do it anyway is the cornerstone
of physical and mental health like yes
do anyway take your meds do whatever you
gotta do do it anyway and so thank you
thank you hannah
it's amazing and the last thing i'll
tell you is moving through this new
season
is gonna take
super tight committed boundaries with
you and your husband who that guy sounds
like a rock star too i mean just an
amazing man um to be able to run up
against his limitations and say
i can no longer
like try to bang my head against this
concrete wall i hope it'll fall down i
gotta take a knee here i gotta call
somebody what a that's a modern day hero
man everybody involved here
um really incredible
really really really incredible
huh
very gross yeah it's just amazing that's
it i like uh she's louise hey we'll be
right back i'm out of words and i never
out of words and so we'll be right back
all right let's take one more let's go
to sarah in kansas city i got my words
back what's up sarah
hi how's it going today good how are you
oh you know just trying to beat this
missouri heat
yes
it's just hot the whole country is hot
hot yes exactly
so what's up
um well i am hoping you can help me
um show empathy to mainly my husband and
family and really be a fun wife again
oh man all right tell me more
so my husband and i have been married
seven years this coming fall we have two
toddlers who are
three and one and a half so obviously a
lot has changed in the last three and a
half years this pregnancy and two small
children coming
coming into our world and you know my
husband just tells me i'm not fun joyful
why city married
i'm mean and grouchy and you know
frankly i feel like that some of the
time okay so um he's not here to defend
himself and so i'm just going to talk to
you okay yep are you mean and grouchy
yeah sometimes i am mean and grouchy yes
um you're hedging your bet um so that
means sometimes you're super fun and
playful and exciting
yep sometimes
uh like on the weekends right and then
during the week it's like business right
like we got the routine with the kids
it's hard for me to break routine it's
um it's this balance now that we have
two toddlers and not babies as this
balance of when to say yes and when to
say no and when to give in to my crying
toddler and when to hold the boundary
right and so that's
um
lucky for you all the internet uh
information is exactly the same it all
just tells you what to do
um okay so
who were you before these toddlers
ruined everything
well we recently started counseling and
i feel
i know lots of help right is helping
um and i feel like some of the
uh
bringing up the you know the i would say
try it's not really trauma but um the
ordeal this is why situation i was given
as a child is now coming up more so
um so my dad passed away when i was a
kid and i grew up with a stepdad who
pretty much gasped lit me my whole life
i never really had a voice in my house
um and i didn't ever find my voice and
so i over compensated to try and fix
everything and i'm apologetic
and so
and hold on
you're you apologize and try to fix
everything
you try to make sure everybody else is
okay
yep
some of that may come from your
gaslighting step dad how old were you
when your dad died
uh two okay
came in at four and a half five okay
my guess and i could be way out to lunch
we had to lunch two and three and four
there's some pretty formative years
there
um
may have been more around the emotional
regulation of your mom
yeah okay
um
you could probably learn at a really
young age if i do this mom
shuts down
mom dealing with dad's the dad's your
dad's passing his grief right
um is a lot
all that to say is this um
we
you have a tether from the past to the
present
yep bring me back here
um
yeah so
i think every time i i mean heck i'm
doing it right now every time i try and
have a hard conversation i start to cry
it's like my instant reaction
um it's not a bad thing
no it just sometimes drives my husband
nuts because he's like we're just having
a conversation why are you crying and
it's like
i can't control it my body just reacts
this way right and then i start to
apologize i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm so
sorry i'm crying i'm sorry that i'm
doing this i don't want to be doing this
you know and i'm trying to fix it
gotcha and so let me tell you this
you're not broken
you you don't you don't need to be fixed
okay
okay your tears are a signal
they're a gift they're letting you know
something about you that you care about
something that's all your husband needs
to kind of get over that
okay gotta move on and this is the pot
talking to the kettle because her to my
wife would cry be like what i do
whatever and she finally was like it's
not about you the whole world's not
about you every thought in my head and
everything in my body doesn't know about
you and i was like oh well played okay
yeah you're not broken
good for you for being a person that
still feels
oh thank you it's awesome it's good
okay you're not broken
okay so
um
who were you before these toddlers
ruined everything
i mean i think i well i think my job has
a lot to do with it i got a new job also
four years ago so let's just throw that
into the mix might as well
um okay let me back up i want to follow
thread i want to make sure i don't lose
this yep were you fun and crazy and
super girlfriend and super fun wife
as a way of
making sure your husband stuck around
no i don't think so i think i was just
more relaxed i think i just didn't
i was a bit in a sense like things just
i didn't hold as much anxiety or if we
do this i'm gonna ruin the kids you know
i'm gonna you know i i'm more structured
now which is probably difficult
um and i think i'm
[Music]
i
i'm just
really struggling to find the balance of
like when you just say screw bedtime
we're gonna you know we're gonna go to a
park on a wednesday night and if the
kids go to bed late who cares
you know even though we have to work on
thursday morning right um
if my husband says hey let's go to the
park and then you know it's i'm looking
at the clock being like at 6 30. our
kids go to bed at seven like does that
make sense you know like okay hold on
there's so much here um okay
i'm gonna just dive right in you tell me
when to shut up okay okay
so um the reason i asked you and your
answer i'm so glad you gave that answer
um i wanted to see if that the emotional
regulation of your mom the gaslighting
if that kind of stuff had you were
playing a role as the super fun person
we all have friends who
played a role at the party they drank a
couple more drinks they were a little
bit louder they made out with a few more
people like
because that was the role they were
assigned in whatever group they were in
right and you tell me that that was
definitely not not my role i was the
girl like driving everybody home and
staying responsible okay so you're okay
and then you met a guy that you loved
and you could anchor into
yes and by anchoring in for the first
time probably in your life
because your dad passed away when you're
young your mom struggled with that grief
and then your stepdad came in and made
you the reason all his life sucked
and
then you felt met this guy and you could
finally go whoo
right
you're hitting the nail on the head john
and then
two things happen
um
the moment you have that first baby
your body has a pin in that and it
remembers
that somebody goes away
okay
yep somebody's gonna go away
and you're looking at that little baby
and you're conjuring up story after
story after story about who's gonna go
away and when and why
and then as the person who drives
everybody home from the party you start
creating lists and objectives and
things and you're going to feed that
anxiety you're going to solve that
anxiety with more data but you're end up
feeding it because you're going to get
some more information you can do this
and it and it becomes an exercise in i'm
going to control every freaking variable
so somebody doesn't go away again is
that fair
well yes that is completely fair and
then it gets more fun
um
you start grabbing the steering wheel so
tight
that the circulation gets cut off in
your hands and you don't even know the
hell you are anymore and the people
around you don't know who you are
anymore and what you do know is your
hands are so tight on that wheel that
you can't reach over and hug that kid
and you can't reach over and grab your
husband by the back of the neck and give
him one of those weird crazy kisses you
used to give him
fair
yes and most importantly
you can't let go of that thing and look
in the mirror and say how sarah doing
and so here's what i want to tell you
okay
somebody's probably not going away
and so there's a moment when you have to
make peace with your body who's trying
to love you and remember the worst
trauma ever
and say thank you
um but we're good now
we're good now
okay and then you've got a three and a
one year old which is just a shake in
the snow globe i mean it's not it's
it's not a hundred percent of i'd have
never met in my life
a couple who's like i got a 300 we had a
three-year-old and a one-year-old and
our sex life is insane i've never met
that couple ever yeah a hundred percent
of couples with a three and a
one-year-old are like i don't know what
day it is i don't even like my husband
he's disgusting and my wife's weird and
she's gotten me i've never i've never
met that couple it's not like that so
you've heard me say this a million times
and i'll say it a million more times
okay
the fun exciting curious adventure to go
on now
is not
anymore
it's not how can we get back to
and that's some language i know he's not
here to defend himself that language has
to go away because anymore
is gone
yeah
pre through two kids
yeah sarah doesn't exist she's a myth
she doesn't exist like she's back there
and by the way pre-two kid's husband
is isn't exist anymore
yeah and so the only question we have is
are there's two questions how can we
drag the past into the future and it's
gonna be a copy of a copy of a copy a
fifth rate
b team jv version of what was
it's gonna be a weird weekend where you
have five drinks so you can become crazy
sarah again and he's gonna get a half
fun half weirded out half tired half
grouchy you know what i'm saying it's
just a copy of a copy and
that's you right now right or yeah
or
y'all are gonna build something totally
freaking new
and say now we have two little kids we
brought into this thing and i still want
to be fun crazy reckless sexy
sarah it's just gonna have to be after
bedtime
which means i'm gonna work on texting
you in the day and getting you fired up
and i'm gonna work on wearing something
different if that's something that
you're gonna talk about and you are
gonna work on helping with bedtime
because that's the hottest thing you can
do right now right yeah or that you're
going to cut your gym short
you can't work out for an hour and a
half you've got to do it for an hour now
because i need those 30 minutes you're
helping with the dishes washing the
bottles whatever the thing is in your
home
it is let's create something new and
we're going to create it for this season
and then that three and the one-year-old
i'm telling you you're about to get
magic corner you get about three years
away from magic when both of those kids
can bathe themselves
and then dude and then go to the
bathroom by themselves
it's like a whole other planet opens up
right and then you're going to recreate
it then and then we're going to recreate
it a little bit later and we're going to
recreate it a little bit you know i mean
so the exercise and the excitement and
the fun is now
let's create something magic and let's
just live into it and the living into it
is fun right we get to do cool stuff
it's that intentionality not not the way
things were is that fair
that's yeah that's completely fair and
for i've not met any couples who that
doesn't become a cool adventure
yeah because then he gets to say here's
what i need
and you get to say here's what i need
and then it's like oh sweet i can make
that happen
you mean all this happens if i just do
those things and then you think the same
thing and then dude now we're in magic
time
yeah that makes sense
that makes sense and let me tell you one
more thing
my wife told me this and it was a really
important moment it's about budgeting
um we would come up with a budget and we
would like we want to have these
financial goals we'd really have a
budget have a budget of a budget and
then we'd get about three weeks in and
we had the last week of the month and
then i'd come home from work really
tired and i would say let's just go out
and eat and i would name some fancy
restaurant
and she'd be like hey it's not in the
thing and i'd be like i know dude it's
the last week let's just go dude we
could this and this and this
and she i did this for years and then
she told me one day
you are using me
you are making it my responsibility to
be the bad guy in this budget thing and
that's not fair
we both agreed on x
and now you're turning it around on me
and making it my fault
and so when it comes to things like
bedtime i think routines and bedtime
with kids is really really important
especially three and under
and so letting your husband know every
time you throw that out
you're making me be the bad guy and it's
not fair
it's not cool okay does that make sense
and usually
he's tired and just wants to go have
some fun with his kids and he doesn't
know what that looks like just playing
with trucks and i don't know what's
happening with a one-year-old just
laying there going
and so let's go to the park it just
sounds like a thing people do on tv
and then he throws it out there and then
you say no and that feeds his story that
my wife just got old and boring
yeah and he throws it out there and that
feeds your story that my husband's
completely unglued on unconnected to
these kids i don't know what's happening
in here why is he see him saying and
then he's become this self-reinforcing
dance
yep so don't have the conversation when
you're upset or when he throws that grin
have it offline in a planning let's
create something new this is new
adventure hey don't make me the bad guy
on these deals if we agree bedtime's
important bedtime's always going to be
important
at least through the first three years
and then if we want to do a surprise
thing here a surprise thing there
awesome let's go do that let's have some
fun adventures about once a month now
once every two months my daughter just
has a night where she's not sleeping
she's six
and i'll go sit out there and i'll read
she'll color we have a magic time she
says it's about an hour and a half later
than normal and she's at peace and then
she goes it's awesome
it's hard to do that with a one-year-old
right occasionally this is hard to do
that with one year old
don't make don't let her make you the
bad guy
so quick recap
your dad passed away and your body's
looking for the next person to leave
especially now that you got these little
ones
probably nobody's going to go so when
that anxiety comes up when your body
comes up when that idea that i need to
grab control i got to grab control when
i start coming up
thank your body
okay thank you for trying to protect me
but i'm good now
i gotta rock
and i'm good good mom
and then you all just excavate
everything what was
the dating y'all the first couple of
four years with no kids y'all
now you have a new adventure
a new sexy romantic fun off-kilter
exciting whatever adventure ahead of you
it's also gonna have regular bedtimes
for the little ones
and plan it and be specific about it and
then go
get it you're awesome sarah we'll be
right back
delony here one of the things i love
about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if i do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as i'd love to i can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
i wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what i would say if you
and i were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book i will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the new roads of a well life
moving forward go to johndaloni.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right we are back in
my uh version of turnstile's mystery at
the beginning of the show i did not do
justice too but here's the lyrics of the
day this is my favorite song ugh so good
um
there's a gun to my head are you gonna
get it right
and i believe in holding on to life but
i'm afraid to
and it's been so long is all the mystery
gone and it's been so long
there's a clock in my head is it wrong
or is it right and i know you're scared
of running out of time but i'm afraid to
and it's been so long
is all the mystery gone
is all the mystery
gone turnstile go check out the glow on
record and for everybody watching
no the mystery's not gone there's more
mystery to be had right here on the dr
john delaney show
coming up on the next episode nobody in
the world calls me dr john except for
people who call the show my friends call
me words that i won't repeat here same
with my wife kelly you call me mean
things not to your face that's a yes
true that's true i watched a show a
while back looking at gas lighting in a
movie tangle my husband and i have been
married over 10 years now and he is an
expert gaslighter if i ask a direct
question and just make me feel like i'm
crazy for asking a question
for whatever reason you ask that one
question and he
feels a certain way doesn't know how to
look in the mirror and say these are my
feelings happening to my body about my
issues the response is
she's making me feel this way so i've
got to turn this back around on her his
dad was very much verbally and
emotionally abusive okay towards me in
front of him okay at the time we lived
together uh my son would step up in
front of me which was shocking because
he was you know little and he would be
like you can't talk to mom like that and
then now i find him now that we're
separated he talks to me similar to the
way his dad used to talk to me here's a
devastating thing about
what you just described abusive
relationships is he knows
that part of you
is part of him and that part of dad is
part of him and so if he identifies dad
as bad or wrong or evil that means part
of him is bad or wrong or evil